Elle Fanning is getting candid about
college a plain transgender and what
it's really like working with Ben
Affleck and they just turned 18 just
graduated high school
so it's kind of it's funny that you feel
like you're starting a new chapter it's
exciting I think College plans
I heard that maybe that's in the works
yes for this year I'm not going at the
moment
because I'm starting a film I don't
think it would be fair because I
wouldn't really be there if I wouldn't
want to kind of have the college
experience we'll see there's always
there's always time I think for that a
lot of buzz surrounding about ray let's
talk about that role in what you had to
do to research that project and and what
you learned from it about Ray was really
one of the most amazing roles I've ever
played probably the most challenging I
played a transgender boy and I got to
meet with so many amazing young guys
just talking to them and hearing their
stories it was powerful you know y'all
never fully feel the way they feel but I
think to have a movie that's about a
transgender teen isn't done often but it
needs to be out there so maybe you know
someone that's kind of going through
what Ray is going through maybe you know
they'll relate to them and I know that
they're being heard about this new
project with Ben Affleck's at you I'd
hope you guys filmed it yet or okay
already rats
anything surprising that you learned
from him well then it's insane because
he wrote the he wrote it and he directed
it and he's starring in the movie so
you're acting with the director it's
crazy and I would love to direct one day
he's thinking like a mile a minute about
everything it's pretty insane so that
was really really cool to see he's of
course Batman do you have an itch about
to get into the comic world yeah that
sounds cool
gosh I am saying
who would I be I mean there's so there's
so many good ones like Batgirl Catwoman
all those you know it'd be amazing now
that neat yeah I would love it